hey Upper East Siders Gossip Girl here
and I have the biggest news ever Gossip
Girl is officially getting a reboot
The CW show will be part of HBO max the
new streaming service by Warner Media
yeah
the same service that has taken friends
back from Netflix it's really excited
yeah be a part of it so far
none of the original Gossip Girl cast
including Leighton Meester Blake Lively
chase Crawford Ed Westwick and Penn
Badgley have confirmed a return to their
roles in the teen soap it was like
college for us you know we kind of grew
up together so that was a very good
experience can you check if I would get
royalties and Joshua Safran an executive
producer for Gossip Girl recently talked
to The Hollywood Reporter about the
show's comeback saying in part we're
also in love with the original and had
such an incredible time working on it
and it's such a big part of our lives
then the stars aligned and we had
availability to jump thanks for making
time ET caught up with chase Crawford
from the original series back in January
where he joked about his involvement in
a potential reboot it's the age of
reboots to people ask you that all the
time could it come back I've heard that
a few times yeah we're getting a little
too old to be there be in college and to
be in our heads of the newspaper
[Music]